we have got some breaking news out of
Washington the FBI is now officially
accusing North Korea of being behind the
Sony hack attack Peter Cook has more
from our DC bureau Peter and this is
something staffing of course we've been
reporting all this week about the
government leaning this direction now
we're expected to get the official word
from the FBI in a statement later on
today according to US law enforcement
official that they will spell out why it
is they think North Korea is in fact
ultimately behind this cyberattack
against Sony that is the big news today
we wait to see exactly what evidence
they'll put forward and then of course
the big question at that point is how
would the United States respond what are
the options available to the government
of course we'll hear undoubtedly
President Obama talked about this today
as well when he has this news conference
at one-thirty p.m. eastern time and what
are some of the options obviously this
is a big WOW it's official but what does
it mean well the options are limited at
this point and again we have to wait to
see exactly what evidence they put
forward whether or not this originated
within North Korea itself or perhaps
surrogates for the North Koreans were
involved outside of the country that
could make a difference in the ultimate
response but it's very hard for example
to target the North Korean
infrastructure the sort of cyber
infrastructure because really there's
only one real pathway out of North Korea
would be easy for the North Koreans to
be able to see the u.s. initiate a
cyberattack what the government even
officially do that more likely Stephanie
what we're thinking or what we're going
to see from the US government is an
effort to name and shame the North
Koreans to raise the profile of what's
happened here get other nations around
the world to focus attention on this and
basically try and embarrass the North
Koreans as best we can and even if there
were a cyber response from the US
government quite likely we wouldn't hear
about it officially for some time